- I am now in front of the
American embassy in Kabul.
This used to be the heart
of the American effort
in Afghanistan for 20 years.
Now everybody's gone. And
the green zone of Kabul,
which used to be the nerf
center of the international
military operations and
civilian reconstruction efforts,
is now an abandoned ghost town.
- Our senior officials also want this to
repair and build good
relations with them again,
and for the embassies to reopen.
- You can see behind me some graffiti
a reminder of the old Afghanistan,
the African Republic that is now gone
and all these watch towers
of the international
coalition headquarters
that has also left Afghanistan
at the end of August.
- [Male] The American
embassy, as far as we know,
has not been penetrated.
However, the odds of American diplomats
returning to Kabul anytime
soon are quite low.
The US has not recognized
the Taliban government as the
legitimate rulers of Afghanistan,
and neither has any
other countries so far.
The several others such as
China, Russia, or Qatar, or Pakistan,
do maintain embassies in
this city and do engage in
contracts with the Taliban authorities.